round 2 of the London chess classic of  the last stop on the grand chest tour  after an unusually early rest day after  the first round 10 of the world's best  chess players came back refreshed and  ready for battle French number 1 Maxime  Vashti la Grove allowed a super sharp  dragon variation in his game against  tactical genius Hikaru Nakamura but  despite all the crazy fireworks the game  ended up fizzling out into a draw when  you've already is like 40 minutes you  kind of just have to move and because  otherwise you got in time pressure and  bad things happen which I mean very  nearly happened in the game anyway with  most of the other games following a  similar script the entire field remains  in a massive type of first place who  will win and break away from the pack  round 3 coming up next